- So former president
Trump was actually able
to get some lawyers to represent him
in the upcoming Senate impeachment trial.
Trump's new lawyers, David
Schoen and Bruce Castor,
seem to have a reasonable
professional background,
but as we've seen time and time again,
sometimes having a reasonable background
doesn't mean you're not
a MAGA hat crazy person.
And here, one of the lawyers
is a solo practitioner
who has been working with Roger Stone
and is an Epstein truther,
and the other was a career prosecutor
who was also the former solicitor general
for Pennsylvania, which is a big wig job,
but also apparently was
one of the prosecutors
who did not prosecute Bill
Cosby in the early 2000s.
Of course, one of the lawyers
has already gone on TV
and said the riots aren't
relevant to the impeachment trial.
- This has nothing to
do with President Trump.
And the country doesn't need
to just watch videos of riots and unrest.
- So it remains to be seen
whether they will go along
with former President
Trump's crazy strategy
of saying that it was all justified
and that it was all
based on election fraud.
But subscribe, or I will see you in court.